[Music]
okay
do
[Music]
hello hello welcome it's nice to see all
of your smiling eyes
tonight welcome to the table my name is
karen miner i am so glad that you're
here tonight that you braved the
summer rain to be here you're in store
for a treat
i just have a couple of announcements to
get us started
first of all one week from tonight we're
going to be doing our very
first round of baptisms here at the
table
yay yeah thank you melody
and so we're going to be doing that a
week from tonight
so in lieu of meeting here at the church
we're going to be meeting at the renford
home which is just down the street like
literally two minutes
and there's going to be food and games
and of course baptism swimming
all of that it's going to be a great
time and we really really want you there
you can find all the information about
the event on our facebook page just look
up the table
on facebook you'll get all of the
details brett has also sent out some
information about the event as well
if you have not gotten that information
and you want it
see brett or see me and we'll be happy
to give you that information
sound good all right secondly speaking
of baptisms
if you are interested in information
about baptisms like what is baptism
why do we do it or you would like to get
baptized next week
brett is going to have a really brief
class immediately following the service
tonight
and he'll get you all the information he
can answer your questions
and you can check that out just meet
brett over here by this door
immediately following the service and
then again it's going to be brief
because then afterwards we're going to
go do dinner at hat creek like we
usually do on the first sunday
of every month so
as you can see a lot of us are wearing
masks that's our preference but again we
are not policing mask wearing and we
really want to be respectful of and
empathetic
towards everybody's preferences so um
it's our preference that you wear the
mask obviously if if it's
completely bothering you we're again we
want to be hospitable
but also help keep each other safe
during this time especially during the
delta variant
so right now i would love to have our
kids director brittany
come up and she's going to share some
special stuff with our kids
tonight hello
okay so our kids this weekend we had
what we are calling summer rama
this was our first year to do it but i
think we will definitely do it again it
was lots of fun
um on friday we played some slip and
slide
kickball and we had some bible lesson
and some worship paintball dodgeball
not with actual paintball guns they were
throwable paintballs
we were not shooting our children um and
then
saturday we had some relays and
we did some friendship bracelet making
and we had a big inflatable water slide
it was lots of fun but they're going to
tell you what they learned this weekend
what y'all learn
s'more jesus me that's right
and right now they are good at maggie is
going to help
lead them in one of our songs that we
learned
and they have some motions that they're
going to show you and they're all very
excited about it aren't you
all right let's go and there's going to
be some pictures up here going while
they're singing if y'all want to see
what they did this weekend
wherever you lead me
me
crazy
like
[Music]
face every challenge every day
you leave me
[Music]
like anything can happen can't hardly
wait to see what's next
i wanna face this world with wonder and
excitement
it's every challenge every day
[Music]
crazy
bye
thank you brittany and kids
y'all did great i love seeing their
different personalities along the stage
we're going to get started with our
worship if you guys would like to stand
with us
we're just going to do a couple songs
together before we have our message
um and we hope that you feel at home and
welcomed here regardless of
what your week has been like or what
your background is that brings you into
this moment
you're in a house that is full of love
so whatever you're carrying with you it
is welcome here
um and feel free to also lay it down and
leave it behind right now if it's
something that
is burdening you that is heavy on your
shoulders
this is a place of freedom and it's a
place of grace
so um just welcome to this space and
enter into worship
knowing that that we want you here and
that
god is with
[Music]
but us on this journey i get lost in my
mistakes
what looks to me like weakness is a
canvas for your strength
and my story isn't
[Music]
no failure won't define me
that's
[Music]
his house
arrival's not the end game the journey's
where you
are you never want it perfect
you just wanted my heart
and the story isn't over if the story
isn't good
the
[Music]
lay your burdens down
here in the father's house
check your shame at the door isn't it
welcome
anymore
you're in the father's house
[Music]
the prodigals come home in the helpless
findhole
love is on the move when the father's in
the room
the prison doors fleeing wide and the
dead come to life
love is on the move when the father's in
the room
miracles take place
[Music]
down
anymore
[Music]
all right we're going to transition into
our prayer the people um and if this is
your first time here just feel free to
join in
we'll get to a part where we're all
going to lift up
people who are on our heart and we
invite you to join us whether you're
online or
here with us in person and karen will
read the ones
online for us
i'm so sorry but for some reason it's
not pulling up on my
but they'll have it back there all right
jesus for the city of saxi texas and for
every city
and community and all of those who live
in them
we pray to you for the good earth that
you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it
we pray to you for those who travel
on land sea or air we pray to you
for the old and the sick for the widow
and the orphan
for the injured and the suffering we
pray to you for the poor and the
oppressed
the unemployed and the destitute for
prisoners and captives and for all who
remember
and care for them we pray to you
lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us
and so now we lift these names and
situations up to you
mariah
our leaders
for these names and moments that we have
spoken out loud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts
we pray to you
that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace
and a deep sense of your presence god
amen
[Music]
in the presence of my enemies
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
heaven comes to fight for me
and i'm gonna sing in the middle
[Music]
is
[Applause]
with everything inside
i will watch the
[Music]
[Applause]
of the darkness
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm gonna see
[Music]
[Applause]
sing a little louder
[Music]
sing a little
a little louder
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm gonna sing in the middle of the
[Music]
story
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
hallelujah
yes can
thank you god for being a part of our
worship for hearing us
and uh for going with us out of this
moment
into this world god we carry you with us
and believe that you are
for us god
in the good times and the bad times that
you are a god who walks with us
who carries us forward and we look to
you god
to continue leading us and guiding us
and it's in your name i pray
amen you guys go ahead and take a second
to turn to the people around you and say
hello
well good evening everyone grace and
peace
uh it's wonderful to be with you so so
good my name is brett i'm the
founding pastor here and um i want to
welcome
uh all of you but especially those who
are new
uh thanks for being here with us and as
well as those joining us
we love y'all lots you're not forgotten
um
so before i jump into our the series
we're in everything i did want to
just give another just a huge thank you
to everyone who
um volunteered and helped out
either behind the scenes or was being
there present for our summer rama
kids camp in fact if you served in that
way it kind of connected to some rama
would you go ahead and stand up so we
can give you
a big applause and we got angie joe
mindy maggie
um y'all it was it was a lot
it was a lot it was so hot outside of
course to stay safe and everything we
wanted
you know we want to be outside but as
you know it was um friday and saturday
so
it was uh 99 degrees and then i think
100 or something
it was just real hot so um so if i sound
a little bit i don't know miss my voice
i kind of lost my voice
i feel very tired so i probably won't
have my normal
youthful enthusiasm but
um anyway i'll just i'll give it my best
and i trust god will speak
god will speak to you all it will be
fine and i'll just do my best so um
we are in let's see it's part four in
our series titled deconstruction
uh finding god again and um
the really the big idea of this series
is there is kind of a phenomena sweeping
um in many ways the western church but
specifically in kind of america
some of you for some of you when i say
deconstruction you're just like i have
no idea what he's talking about and you
know another
manager like oh yeah of course that's
like a total thing
so for those who um maybe are unfamiliar
the idea of deconstruction is
is basically um people often describe it
like they'll
say almost uh like a you know like a
verb like i'm just i'm in a season of
deconstructing
you know and what they mean is they are
um
kind of they have received certain
theologies certain
um images of god we call it kind of
pictures of god which we all kind of
operate with and um they have certain
theological ideas
they have um just you know certain
teachings sometimes it's christian
theology usually it's in a christian
context that they're really wrestling
with and they've received all these
things
um but for various reasons maybe it's
intellectually like i just can't make
sense of this
or a lot of times it's about the heart
you know and it's like emotionally like
i receive
all this theology i receive like this is
the the way the you know this is the
the truth of christian faith and um
but now i'm struggling with it and
wrestling with it and
often what what people don't realize is
they were given a certain version
of christian certain interpretation
which may not actually
even be all that historically rooted
like in actual christian theology and
tradition
you know but for us i mean if
something's 100 years old it's like whoa
ancient right when in reality
christianity i mean it's like 2 000
years old
right so so often we can be quite um in
step with the times
and yet be very out of step with
christian
thought down through the centuries and
so a lot of what um kind of what we're
doing in deconstruction is really
wrestling with okay what have i
inherited uh here that maybe actually
doesn't make sense
or um maybe just it's not serving me
anymore
um it's maybe hurting me and we have you
know a really
strong engine of folks from the lgbtqi
plus you know community here
so for them of course this is like often
a process they have to go through a
deconstruction a wrestling with
what's the bible what does god say like
what
how do i make sense of this who am i
what you know it's this whole process so
um so while deconstruction is kind of
broader than just that
um we do you know it's and series
is really broader than that um it's
still it's i think just it's really
timely and relevant for us
all right there we go thank you um so
all right with that in mind i promise
last week we talked a lot about our
image of god
um so if you missed that message you can
go back and listen to it on our podcast
but
i kept promising like we'll get to
scripture we'll get to the bible like
how do we think of the bible what is the
bible and you know all that
so um so this is the week we will jump
all
into it and i'm really excited about it
so
the title of my message is uh
deconstruction in
bible and here's where i'd i'd like to
begin with
just a few statements to kind of frame
our discussion tonight
if scripture is a body then
christ is the heart if scripture
is a journey then christ is
the destination if scripture is a canvas
then christ is the painting if scripture
is a harmony
then christ is the melody if scripture
is
a boundary then christ is the center
if scripture is a door then
christ is the key
and and what i'm getting at with these
kind of metaphors
um is um is basically by saying like
okay so christ is he's the painting he's
the center he's
the heart he's the you know all you're
kind of getting with all these images
i'm hoping to hit it from different
angles so that you
hopefully you get it there's like 10 of
them so here i think you're tracking
um what i'm kind of getting at is
actually
more than saying um you know for example
scripture
it's a very long story and christ
happens to come at the end and so he
kind of gets the last word
though in ways that's true but i'm
that's not quite what i'm
that's not really my point um nor am i
saying
that something as simple as reduced as
you know
christ is the best part about the bible
though again i think that's true
um but but i'm what i'm kind of trying
to say is more than that what i'm saying
is um that without christ
at the very center of the scriptures
and in a sense guiding us you might even
use the metaphor of lens like when you
put on glasses and you see through
like without christ as that lens to see
through without him as really the
heartbeat and kind of our guide
to scripture it is incredibly easy
to read the bible in such a way that we
do
unbelievable harm to
um i mean sometimes ourselves uh
our communities even the world and now
that's kind of putting it uh
kind of to sum that up you might say
without christ we can read the bible
our readings of the bible can go
horribly wrong now that's kind of put it
in the negative to put it in a more
positive slant
i would say with christ as the center as
the painting as the heartbeat of the
text and that kind of
guiding us all the way what that allows
us to do is to kind of
draw out all of the beauty
and the goodness and the life
from this wonderful story of scripture
that we have
while avoiding what would be
not those things right the opposite what
would
um what would be i mean honestly at
worst um
very violent uh destructive and harmful
readings
of of scripture um so okay so what does
it kind of mean to say we're gonna
okay so we want christ to be the he's
the painting he's the center he's
the heart he's okay so like in a more
kind of tangible way
what is how does that pay off where does
that go and
um what i'm trying to kind of get us
thinking about
is is that when we um
when we read the text and we come to
certain passages
that kind of strike us not simply as
uncomfortable they don't just make us
uncomfortable because that can be a good
thing
right to have the bible kind of
challenge us or get us thinking in new
ways that's not
always bad um but i'm talking about when
we come to a certain text
and it strikes us as deeply deeply sort
of
problematic precisely because we have
christ in mind
right it seems to somehow be intention
or contradiction with
who um who christ is his character
that when that happens because
christ is the center the heart the
painting and so on
because it's the case when that moment
happens where we bump up against the
text and we're like oh what do i do
with this that is a sign that we
should shift into a
different mode of reading one
that does not operate solely at the
literal level
of the text but shifts into a
more um we might call it spiritual and
past centuries christians call it
allegory or
symbol or um uh kind of a non-literal
level i mean we'll get into in a second
into kind of a practical example if it's
still a little bit
vague of like what on earth would that
mean um
so before i jump into the example though
i want to name that what i just
described
this is basically how ancient christians
read
the old testament in particular and it
strikes us
perhaps as somewhat strange because for
the last few hundred years maybe
three four hundred years maybe 500 it
has not been the kind of dominant way to
approach the bible
and yet for the first 1 500 years this
is everyone from
actually st paul in the new testament to
origen um to gregory of nissa to saint
augustine
like this was what they did uh
and they um
uh so so i guess what i'm kind of naming
is that although it may strike us as
like
somewhat different um or even new
like is this a is this a newfangled idea
you're bringing our way
um no it's actually an old fangled idea
uh i don't know if that's a word
but it will be now old thing right it's
it's but it's so
old that it strikes us now as new uh
does that make sense
so um if you're yeah if you're wondering
like where is he coming well
i mean i'm trying to preach like what as
i understand it the new testament is
guiding us to do but
hey that's okay so uh we're all wrestle
we'll all be on the journey if you
disagree by the way it's okay i'm not
here to like
make everyone agree it's cool do what
you want but
i hope i can at least get you thinking
in some fresh ways about how do i
approach scripture
so with that in mind let's jump into an
example
an example tonight this is a passage
it would i mean almost certainly this
would have to fall
kind of under the banner of problematic
story from the old testament
um it is from first samuel chapter 15
and it's these types of passages that
really they tend to kind of launch
people into a season of deconstruction
that word we're using earlier right this
is a great text of like
i have a certain way of viewing god i
have a certain way of viewing the bible
all of a sudden i've heard read first
samuel scene and it shoots my wheels
completely off
i don't even know if i can be a
christian anymore like this is the types
of things that happen
to uh to people so we'll we'll use it as
i think it's a great example all right
so let's read uh one day samuel so
samuel was
a prophet he said to saul this saul will
be the king
it was the lord who told me to anoint
you as
king of his people israel now listen to
the message from the lord
this is what the lord of heaven's armies
has declared
i have decided to settle accounts with
the nation of amalek
for opposing israel when they came from
egypt now
go and completely destroy the entire
amalekite nation men
women children babies
cattle sheep goats camels and donkeys
oh this is
the bible this is the word of the lord
right this um
can you see this moment i mean i can
kind of feel you all kind of
what do i do with that okay maybe maybe
he is naming something that's kind of
true in the bible
because i think sometimes we um like if
you ever get a verse a day app
they will never give you first samuel
15. that never pops up you know like if
you're a little morning devotional
you know uh nope they just jump right
and actually even folks who because
that's kind of more of a i don't know
protestant thing to do verse a day
um even more liturgical whether catholic
or others you'll notice in their
liturgies like
you know they have their old testament
reading the gospel reading the epistle
reading you know
um what do they never include right so
every every christian tradition kind of
has its ways of kind of like
right so for evangelicals we kind of
skirt around with this you know verse a
day
and yeah we all have our way so okay so
what do we um
why is this so problematic well i think
at one level it's fairly clear
um in terms of the especially
killing of the non-combatants i mean
maybe you know in a certain perspective
you could argue like well
the men of war or something you know um
but it's it's
especially with children i remember
being in a seminary class and um
we were discussing this passage actually
or at least or i should say one like it
one there's others that are very similar
and i remember two guys getting into an
argument because one gentleman was
trying to kind of defend a text like
this
because right he had a certain view of
scripture and was like i'm going to
defend the bible you know
and someone the other guy kind of just
had his mic drop moment when he said
look man
killing children is always wrong
and the guy's like well i just you know
maybe if the lord and he's like
it's always wrong and it just sort of a
hush descended over the class i mean it
was just like
yeah i think that's probably true um so
now one thing folks will do with
passages maybe similar to this
is say like well okay just because
people do things in the bible
doesn't mean it has two thumbs up from
god
right which is true um that's precisely
that what's so tricky about
this text in particular is that it has i
mean basically the first two verses
are the prophet samuel i mean the way he
frames it
right is by beginning by saying hey saul
remember how it was the lord who spoke
to me prophetically
to install you as king do you remember
that that moment
all right you do good um because now i
have a follow-up word
from god to you i mean can you see how
it's like layer upon layer of
it was the lord who told me to anoint
you as king of his people israel now
listen to this message from the lord
verse two
this is what the lord of heaven's armies
has declared yeah there's really no
sliding out from you know uh from this
idea
okay um so so what happens so i'm
summing up the whole chapter
i encourage you to go back later and
read the whole thing it's a fascinating
um if disturbing but fascinating story
um
but there's this moment where
well so basically what does saul do so
he he
obeys mostly um oddly enough he spares
uh some of the animals um not because he
was a merciful fellow but because
um he won it as kind of plunder for war
that was sort of like
the upside if you're a war you're going
to battle the upside is you get stuff if
you win
so so he keeps some of the um animals
and uh as well as the king of the
amalekites agag
is his name he spares his life for some
reason so samuel the prophet shows back
up after the battle
there's this famous line i think um
towards the end of the chapter
where he says um in the king james it's
something like
what is this bleating of sheep
and lowing of cattle that i hear that's
kind of the king james this version
and he's basically saying to saul why am
i hearing noises
i shouldn't be hearing noises and then
samuel the prophet sees agag the king
probably cowering in the corner and
realizes saul has spared him
and so this is uh verse 33
it says and samuel cut ag to pieces
before
the lord at gilgal
yeah um i mean no i think what's so
disturbing isn't simply that it's
sort of graphic and violent this is like
quentin tarantino stuff
but it's it's that it goes a little
deeper like it's i think it's the whole
before the lord
can you hear the description there like
in the same way we might say and they
worshipped before the lord they sang
songs before the lord they you know i
mean and now suddenly
we're cutting people to pieces before
the lord
it's just can and can you see how this
is somewhat intention um
being a little bit cheeky but some
intention with jesus and you know love
your enemies and pray for those who
persecute you
if someone slaps you on the right cheek
turn to them the other also can you kind
of
right can you see how it's like okay how
do i make sense of this what am i doing
um so uh now you might think
that that you know early christians just
write a text like this and said well the
bible said it
i believe it and that settles it um but
no
no actually um this is back to the whole
first 15 centuries of christianity
um they they were different so now they
had little different on-ramps or
different ways of kind of grappling with
a text like this
the first one that i'll mention is a
gentleman named marcian
he was ultimately deemed a heretic by
the church
but but i think him is wrestling with
the problem you can see why he's
wrestling
with texts like these right so sometimes
people are quite uncharitable towards
him like he was just a bad christian but
you know if you really take a minute to
read a chapter like this you can see why
he'd do this so his
his perspective was basically look texts
like first samuel 15
and others i could give you a dozen
others um are proof
that the god of the old testament is
nothing but
a a sort of crazy dimmy urge demi god
clearly in no way connected to the god
we've come to know in jesus
therefore christians must eliminate the
old testament from their reading
just become new testament christians we
just we just need the new testament
forget that old testament that was
marcion's kind of um
solution and and uh and it was that
solution so to speak that the church i
think
rightly so um rejected and said no
um no we're not gonna do that we're not
gonna go that road
um and there's a number of reasons why i
mean for at the very least it's simply
that
um i mean hey there's so many beautiful
passages in the text like there's so
there's so much goodness in the old
testament that just kind of be like oh
well there's
some problems so we're just gonna ditch
the whole thing is weird also it's the
whole background
and storyline for christ right you just
cut out the whole old testament all of a
sudden jesus just sort of shows up and
it's like oh okay what's
where's he coming from right it's sort
of the whole context it's the whole
background and the whole backstory
so on the one hand christians wanted to
kind of keep the story
and yet realize that chapters like this
are kind of problematic so what did they
do uh
well this um this kind of leads us to
where we begin
what they did was they they read it um
what they called it like spiritualized
or allegorized
and so someone like for example the
church father origin who preached a
sermon on this
this exact text and what he said
was that this stories like these
are to be read as stories about the
internal struggle of the christian
because we fight not against flesh and
blood
but against sort of the powers and
forces of evil kind of in the unseen
world
so he said this is how christians should
read these types of texts
not as literal just so stories of
yes this happened and then god said and
you know but as sort of parables
of sorts um for example he he named he
said all the
the the ice in the bible if you've ever
had the old testament you know there's
like the hittites and the amalekites and
the amorites and you know
moabites um he said how do we read these
texts do we read them as as literal
stories of things that happened he said
no of course not like because we worship
christ
and this is in contradiction to who
christ is real got to be
he said no what do we do instead he said
i see that these are symbols
these nations are symbols of everything
that stands
opposed to god in his purposes
and and so the point of for example a
text like first samuel 15
um is is that is it's a parable about
what do we do with sin origin said he
said do we
keep a little off to the side kind of
for ourselves like
or when we surrender to god do we give
our full selves he said how do we
approach
sin and wrong doing in our life he said
we cut it off we fight it
all the way to the end
this was um how origen approached a text
like first samuel 15. i think it's
actually a really sharp reading i don't
know if i could like literally preach
an exact sermon just like that i'm not
sure i'm still you know um
this is um
this is kind of uh it is it's a fresh
way right of of reading the text and yet
at another level um i kind of wonder
like
is is it is it is this such a strange
way of approaching the bible
or is it actually um kind of how we've
been doing it
all along um
and i want to give you just a quick
example so earlier we were singing a
song
raise a hallelujah and i heard you all
were liking the song like you were kind
of like singing it out and stuff which
is really cool
um and what's interesting about this
this song in ways i did i set you all up
for this i did because i told many like
you need to
if you could sing that song that would
be awesome um
and if you'll notice so what are these
these lyrics i raise a hallelujah in the
presence of my enemies
i raise a hallelujah louder than the
unbelief i raise a hallelujah
my weapon is a melody i raise the
hallelujah heaven comes to fight for me
now if you like know your old testament
there are echoes here
of war passages from the old testament
this is actually why i remember
processing this song with mindy and she
was really wrestling with whether we
should ever sing this song
because it kind of has that goes maybe
not first samuel 15 so much but it's
more um those battles against all the
ites as the
israel was taking the promised land and
what the either moses or joshua would
often say
would be watch as the lord fights for
you this day israel
like watch as he eliminates your enemies
here we go like that was that's kind of
the so there's echoes
um of those passages in this song
um and yet i think it's so beautiful
that what has the writer of the song
what have they done
i mean can you even catch it my weapon
is a melody
like my weapon is worship can you see
what they've done like and so now even
though if we were to read those actual
texts
we might be slightly horrified like oh
my gosh what you know it sends us into a
deconstruction crisis
and yet here we sing it with shouts and
amens and yes
lord why because what what are we doing
well
we're reading the bible right we are
we're starting we understand jesus
is the painting jesus is
the center he's the heart he's
he's everything and then we start with
christ in him as the norm of scripture
and then we go
back and we re-read and we reinterpret
the entire bible from
christ in who he is
and and so i've been kind of wrestling
this week and thinking through so like
okay so what's the payoff here
and i want to close um just by naming
this about how we approach the bible
i think what this kind of reading does
of this form of reading what it opens us
up to
is a much more relaxed and
kind of spirit-driven way of reading the
text
which again honestly as i think about it
this is exactly how my grandma read the
bible
like with no formal theological
training or anything
but every verse spoke to her like oh my
gosh god was just saying to me this
morning through such and such
you know second corinthians whatever
like some random thing and it's just
speaking right to her
and i i think that actually in a way
this lets us kind of lets us re-engage
the bible again
even after we've seen all of its kind of
warts and struggles and you know for
samuel 15s and like oh my gosh
and we can all of a sudden when we
realize okay look
well i might sum it up like like this um
it's the bible we've we've misunderstood
it in ways
the bible is not an encyclopedia or a
scientific manual of god
facts it is a spiritual book and it must
be read spiritually
with the ear of our heart attuned to god
and so what i think that kind of opens
up for us is this whole way of
approaching the bible
that is just open to the spirit and just
saying lord what do you
want to speak in fact there's a whole
tradition called spiritual reading or
lectio divina
which is you read a passage over and
over and you just ask lord
what do you want to speak and then just
wait for god to kind of highlight
a word a phrase something that jumps off
right and what would it do i mean with
that in mind you could actually read
first samuel 15
in which you might think i could never
use that in a devotional
and yeah who knows like suddenly some
word some image right if you're willing
to
engage it with these eyes not at the
literal level which is obviously
problematic
but saying lord what do you want to say
to me what do you want to speak to me
and when we do that i'll just speak for
myself what this has done is kind of
freed me
to engage the bible um without so much
angst anymore
because i was i was in a season where i
was well a there was a season where i
was just hacked off of the bible
because of these types of texts you know
first samuel and i was just like oh my
gosh i don't even know what to do with
this
and i got you know so i didn't read the
bible for like i don't know it was a
while
two years probably um and then
once i started to realize like well
basically learn about church history and
to realize oh so i don't have to take
like
everything literally oh didn't realize
that okay um then all of a sudden
all of my angst sort of melted away and
now i could just be open to what god was
saying
and so i think it's beautiful because it
it it helps us be have a much more
playful kind of relaxed relationship
with the bible
by playful i don't mean like flippant or
something but i just mean
open to the spirit of god god can use
anything he can use any chapter he can
use any verse
and at the same time i don't feel the
need to defend
the every verse or chapter of the bible
um boy we had a lot of christians a lot
of defensive christians in the united
states
um so it helps us just kind of chill out
everybody chill out relax and just be
open again to the god who speaks to us
in scripture
um so all right that's all i got let me
pray for you guys
lord jesus um i thank you
for this community and
just what your what you're speaking to
us what you're communicating
and your heart god your heart um that is
in scripture in
in is communicated to us and i pray that
um we would just be open god to your
leading open to your spirit
who is so faithful and speaks
yeah god so do do your good work in us
christ say my prayer
amen so we are going to be engaging
communion
tonight and um i know not everyone's
necessarily familiar with this
this practice so this is a very ancient
christian practice
that it goes all the way back to the
night jesus was betrayed he had one
final meal
with his disciples and at that meal at
one point he stood up and he broke a
loaf of bread
and he said this is my body and then he
held up a cup of wine
and he said this is my blood whenever
you eat this bread
whenever you drink this cup remember me
and so for 2000 years
christians have come to the table to
remember again who christ is to to
re-center so to speak
and so my encouragement to you as you
come tonight is in the same way i i'd
love for you to begin kind of engaging
with god
in um less anxious ways
that was kind of our theme last week
it's the theme of this week you know
coming to the scriptures even
less defensive and um angsty
and that's the same heart posture i'd
like you to bring tonight
as you come to the table just trusting
god is good
christ is faithful and um
and so you're all welcome to to join us
and participate we do practice what's
called an open table meaning if you're
here tonight
and you'd like to engage and you just
trust that somehow
trust that christ is present i don't
know how it all works but i trust that
you're present
um then you know what you're welcome to
to come forward
so we do have uh a small um
thing of gluten-free bread here so if
that's you then
you can use that one um i know our
process is a little bit different
with our masks and stuff so we're going
to ask is that
in a moment brandon and kaitlyn are
going to come up to serve you the
elements
and you can just form a line you know
leave a little space few feet of space
in between you the next person
when you come forward you can just slip
off your mask you know and then take
your elements
and then just put it back on you know
after you finish um
all right i think that's all the details
so
this is the table not of the church
but of the lord and it's made ready for
those who love him and for those who
want to love him more
so come you who have much faith
and you who have little you who have
been here often
and you who have not been here long you
who have tried to follow
and you who have failed come
because it's the lord who invites you
and it is his will
that those who want to meet him should
meet him here
come to the table
[Music]
do
we're gonna close with this uh song
which is really a story of
someone else's deconstruction process so
you guys feel free to just sit back
and listen to the words enjoy carter's
beautiful guitar
playing and um yeah i hope that it's
maybe something that we can all relate
to in different parts
[Music]
when i was born you were my breath
you were my skin against your breast
you were my food you were my light
you were my it's always
only ever been
it's always only ever been
[Music]
you
and then i met you on the wall
you are seventeen inches tall
[Music]
a painted smile upon your face
i prayed for heaven prayed for grace
[Music]
i gave my life when i was ten
i prayed in tongues was born again
it's always only ever been
[Music]
as the spiral paired the seams and the
brand new colors gleamed
i could only think of you
you were there
every broken heart entangled care
jesus savior lord and king all my friend
and everything it was always only
you i saw the writing on the wall
you were a man and that was all
there was no god in heaven above
there was no perfect saving love
it was only ever me
it was always only me
[Music]
so
and then my world was torn apart i felt
a ground
i felt a heart
and all the universe was one
[Music]
just like a father's spirit
it's always ever
[Music]
pairs the seam as the holy haunts my
dreams
i'll stay right here with you
[Music]
you were there
every broken heart and tangled
care jesus teacher brahman light
son of god and source of life it's
always only you
[Music]
thanks you guys that was beautiful love
that
thank you so much for joining us tonight
i hope that the service
blessed you and helped you to feel more
connected
um before you leave i just want to
highlight a couple of announcements
number one don't forget about the
baptism class that's happening
immediately after the service just meet
brett right over here by the exit door
you're not like leaving the building
there's another room over there
secondly we are doing our first sunday
of the month
dinner at hat creek i'm not sure what
the weather is like outside but i do
know their patio area over there is
covered
it's the hat creek and saxi so
we would love for you to join us over
there for dinner right after the service
and then don't forget about next sunday
we will not be here we'll be at the
baptism party at the runford home
so we hope to see you there for that
lastly
let me send you out into your week with
this benediction if you
can please stand
you are a child of god
this is true on your best day and it's
true
on your worst day so as you go out
into the week ahead with its yet to be
determined highs
and lows and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy and you are accepted
just as you are and go filled with god's
holy spirit
and that same desire to give those gifts
of unconditional
love and grace to everybody you come in
contact with
this week be blessed and we hope to see
you on sunday at the baptism party
[Music]
i see the words breaking and falling
i see hate building up
all of
[Music]
what did okay
okay
i see